[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
oh
bonjour monsieur je vais mieux l'hôtel
du temps qui dois-je annoncé ba moi
voilà oui oui mais qui soit à peu près
si vous êtes laissés tentés mauvais
profil télévision ont montré tué lors
d'ue son art 10 ans volatile j'ai rendez
vous là à que de temps perdu à gagner du
temps monsieur ardisson prenez votre
temps ici les secondes durant des
siècles
mon
m
[Musique]
oh
j'ai pas au mauvais caractère j'ai du
caractère c'est tout alors forcément tu
comprends quand on a du caractère il est
toujours mauvais pour les autres à ce
qu'on fait parce qu'ils veulent un lino
ventura était vraiment un ami on se
voyait tous fermés tes copines moi la
femme libre à qui personne n'a dictait
sa loi un même parti que la gt au petit
soin pour toi mais ça n'a pas suffi pour
te garder bonjour je voyais dans quinze
jours bonjour princesse
non stéphane dame n'aurait jamais commis
cette erreur comment vivez-vous votre
mort monsieur le président au dessus
mais pas la mort qu un grand souci chez
lui ne plus vivre je vous laisse
regarder j'ai tout votre temps oui si tu
savais le temps que j'ai mis à piger du
temps non il ya eu un bide le jour se
lève et gens n'ont pas aimé des
flashbacks qu'est ce que c'est la
première fois qu'il voyait puis après ça
a été étudié dans les universités mais
ainsi jean je vais vous laisser vous
reposer
tout seul moi j'ai du temps
je sais je sais je sais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux